hey guys merry here with a not-so-great
gamespot news update sounds like
rockstar is delaying GTA 5 for pc again
this is kind of changing the overall
well-known slogan from pc master race2
pc last place for the third time
rockstar has delayed the pc release of
grand theft auto 5 pushing the launch to
april 14 the game was initially
scheduled to ship in fall of 2014 and
then in late january and then on march
24 this third delay pushes the release
back by three more weeks rockstar said
our apologies to PC gamers worldwide who
have been counting down the days until
the launch of our game but a bit more
time is needed to ensure that the game
is as polished as possible as a gesture
of goodwill players who pre-ordered the
game will receive a
two-hundred-thousand-dollar in-game cash
bonus to use in GTA online this brings
the total pre-order bonus to 1.5 million
there's also some good news for the
owners of released versions of GTA 5
because long-awaited heist mode has been
given a launch date of March 10th now
Rockstar said we'll be releasing more
information on heists in the next few
weeks but until then you can check out
the high res screen shots they just
released over at gamespot.com / news